noah peut-être peut-être je dirais non
pour les droits humains
aucun souci est ce que si votre fille
vous venez vous voir en vous disant
qu'elle veut d'épouser un noir ça vous
paraît très gênant peut pas dire que ça
me fait très plaisir quand même est-ce
que si votre fille venez vous voir en
vous disant qu'elle veut épouser un noir
ça vous paraît très gênant encore une
personne de couleur noir n'ont
absolument pas très bonne
pourquoi voulez que je développe c'est
une question d où la des années 50-60 ça
c'est pas que on veut y apparaît noir
mais enfin malgré tout se fait pas il me
semble ça fait quelque chose auprès des
amis auprès des parents les y retient il
a une fille qui se mariait valois
peut-être peut-être je dirais pas noir
je crois pas que la halle la couleur et
une quelconque importance ans ont vu je
me demande vraiment vraiment très bon
vraiment vous essayer de la faire
revenir sur sa décision
je crois qu est ce que vous lui diriez
pas je lui dirai que
il ya des blancs quand même sur la terre
moi je ne vois pas des gens noirs des
gens blancs des jaunes canal me donne
quoi que ce soit la véritable on la sait
c'est vraiment dépassé après les avoir
connus ces gens là peut-être ce sont des
gens très bien quoi ce serait dur mais
c'est vraiment à l'écrire on peut pas
aller contre les questions pour nous
c'est vraiment bas de soie heureuse ma
fille en fait
est-ce que vous envisageriez d'épouser
un noir non non vous n'avez jamais pensé
non jamais et est-ce que vous
envisageriez d'épouser or noir
oui enfin je m'en fous oui pourquoi pas
là j'ai déjà quelqu'un dans ma vie mais
si il était noir ça changerait rien pour
moi je faisais pas la kul qua non à la
personne n'a dit si ça résonne
mutuellement dans le coeur pourquoi pas
[Musique]